タイマーで名鑑まゆちゃこの地元の店ミスでチューリップフェアっていうチューリップ
のお祭りがあるんですけど持たせていただきます
恋来いほんじゃあ弾みそうです皆僕の誕生日で feb14
僕が28歳になってからもう2週間経とうとしていますこういうご時世なんでバタバタ
してるし
これ誕生日順に第二審があって寝てるか
お祝いするブートじゃなかったんですけどユーチューバーの皆誰一人俺にプレゼント
あげてないよねー
ちょっとネタなんかちょっとなんて言うでしょ厚かましいというのは事実承知なんです
けどまぁ事実的な結果として誰一人ユーチューバーから誕生日プレゼント終わってい
ないという結果今こちらであるということだけお伝えさせていただきます
というわけで僕の誕生日そんな寂しいので終わらせたじゃないわけですよ
ユーチューバーでだる舌作れんともらったらいいかって皆さん知ってますからそう
光さんですあの人だったらきっと担当イベ全部くれてたら多分
くれると思うんですよどんどんこれこういう厚かましい臭くないんですけどどうせ
もらったらもらいたいですちょっともにー
柱が立ってるんですけど光さんにちょっと記事4
よしあつもしもし光る私よとした
を一からあっ
おっとしたんです
光るあの俺さー
あ
もう2週間経ってんだよねー
これ誕生日からも2週間経ってんだよね
引かれた俺誕生日からも20語ってる目線を控えさん
半島ベッド9日系もらったら
以下らしさ
アーサーありがとうございますから日から俺あの
誰か府からも誕生日プレゼントもらってなくて
焼いてもらってはいるんですけどあの
んユーチューバーかっっうっはーなるほど
ユーチューバー金チャイから片っ端からまたよといいかなんですからしか欲しくない
です
俺からこしひかりさんからのプレゼントが欲しいわかるほどです
が解けると明日東京行きます
じゃあ人前
なんかプレゼントしようかじゃあ本当にこれのセンスとアルファ
琉球 youtube です皆さん保留チームでオレンジだよ俺の北行きましたが入っ
近い倉庫前それまでもゆチューバー誰からプレゼントをもらおうかなって思ったティた
んですよ
俺が1年1回ぐらいはからしょうがないなじゃあちょっと者
第4 q の2が考える武器かレザー5
ぽけじゃあまたねあしたりすいませ報道を合わせですけど
牛からさんが走りそれしか
ありがとうございますおやすみなさいお気を付けでん
ありがとうお寄せください
[音楽]
たのでー
やったぁー
うわぁみんなやったぞ一番金をばらまきそうなユーチューバー karu さん
そんな方がした技は僕にパン剃りプレゼントかけます但してみたこと
糸限りました
じゃあまた明日いい
[音楽]
私ウォレットしっかーし
ますか本場痛いな
ください
考えに考えてすごいを用意してしまったまず
早速りーあーあじゃあそうですもうちょっと私ちょっときつまたしたティッシュを
命ずるって思いました
マジだったな的士トップたまにだから彼らがお子ちゃましてもチケとなりに入っちゃっ
たままぢまぢ
なにそれ
あっはいどこさ
なんかもっ
ダメっしょハイタイプ前と同じおめでとう
def
えっ2
誰か分からん
今のところちょっと混ぜてるでも仲はいい感じはありますよ
これはから入りました誰か買った
すっきゃらかーんちょっとわからないでしょ
有名なかというかめちゃくちゃいいねぇヤバイ人にロビナすぎて誰もわからない曲
えっていうのもそれなら
聞く金さんのマネージャーさんあっほら
オーナーくれたからねアベルその折が違ったや本スペル
スペインで読んだら今から鳥羽なってくるしますよ
今立ちました
マズルカん
本物ですかあれっこんな感じですよあっほんといつかさんに似てるって言うのではない
のさせど似てる女のドロドロとぞ
気づけよまあね風すとこれはまぁまぁまぁまぁ前哨戦ということでまだあるんですね
冷めついてくるさあどうぞにはちょっと引っかかってくれるかなと思ったよ
リアクション面白かった
ありがとうございますじゃあちょっとガチのやつを
さあ
はいえっ
一応ねうんうんっ
re 1 f 4はっはっはあるされます
こーいちふなっちゃうあるいは不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
[音楽]
louis vuitton でまぁ結果ありきたりないけどファイバーの中では
でもこのプレゼントは肇社長なられ
マジすか当て思って
これん
失礼しますいきますね
[音楽]
これはに入れ実用性ありまずシャワー室寄せ合い
ん
なにこれアタッシュケースみたいやった思い
ねっ
めっちゃかっけサイコロめっちゃ入ってる遊戯王で使える
台数を3人のタイプ羽根所はカードにつける
めっちゃ好き住んでた=使うダカールだりありましたじゃあまあたまに早いねそうだろ
これ大会出るときにリピーターのサイトを利用して行ったらいくつよ正しく空いて
るって触れるし放送まずまずアリー品から0
たら最高なんですこれが目物をデザート+ねもうちょい過ぎこれで来ぽいど8000
って書けばいいですねそうへいギアをするときにこれやっていう
なるほどそのとこんなのルーターある一言を守る
教室たいけど限ってペンもついて上もついて超オシャレで良いインテリアとしてもまず
そもそも車輪しこれが増えたくなる4個のサイコロでカッコイイですねめちゃカッコ
4本ちょっとカメラで案のうちらもいいけど相当かっこいいで
louis vuitton なンウゲーメッツ受け
遊キッズうえおこれ結構高いからさ
パパちゃん白ください
風格が今たさんビックリしちゃうの趣味に合わせてなんてくださったのまず嬉しいです
ええええええまあもちろんもちろんありがとうございます行かれちゃう
2028ですこれは何というお店
あっと1個します
エアー友禅染とっています
移しますあっひっ
[音楽]
ブーブー言っに
て良いこれ
うさつ
関連するはそれ動画たらしいいいでしょ